Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at NoFrills.ca. The manuscript from which the work of Thomas of Monmouth is printed here, and it is the only copy of his work which is known, formed part of a library bequeathed about the year
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。No Frills 为您送货上门。通过 PC Express 从 No Frills 订购杂货送到您家。在线购物并在前五笔订单中获得价值 15 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。立即前往 NoFrills.ca 购物。托马斯·莫茅斯（Thomas of Monmouth）著作印本所依据的手稿（这也是其著作现存唯一的已知抄本）曾是大约公元
1700 to the parish of Brent Ely in Suffolk by a certain Mr. Edward Coleman, sometime of Trinity College Cambridge. The collection included some nine manuscripts, and among them were two of no ordinary interest. One was the Gospel Book of St. Margaret of Scotland, which was purchased by the Bodleian Library in 1887. The other was the volume containing the life of St. William. Seven out of the nine manuscripts are now in the university library at Cambridge. And since I'd been myself to some extent instrumental in procuring these books, it was with... You're doing so well, Dominic. You're doing so well.
1700年左右，萨福克郡布伦特伊利（Brent Ely）教区的一位爱德华·科尔曼先生（Mr. Edward Coleman）遗赠给教区的一批藏书的一部分，他曾就读于剑桥大学三一学院。这批藏书大约包含九份手稿，其中有两份具有非同寻常的价值。其中一份是苏格兰圣玛格丽特的《福音书》，于 1887 年被博德利图书馆（Bodleian Library）购得。另一份则是包含圣威廉传记的册子。这九份手稿中有七份现藏于剑桥大学图书馆。而且，既然我本人在促成这些藏书的购入方面发挥了一定作用，那么……多米尼克，你表现得太棒了。你表现得太棒了。
It was with extreme pleasure that on examination I discovered first that here was a copy of Thomas of Monmouth's Life of St. William, and next that no other copy seemed to be known. It is written in a fine hand or two hands on good parchment in double columns. It retains its original wooden boards, formerly fastened by a strap and pin. Its date I should place somewhat before 1200." So if you like ghost stories, especially the classic ghost stories of the late Victorian early 20th century period, people in the Sputter Viola scene I did a sort of necromantic gesture. Yes, you did. Very frightening. It evoked the spirit of a Christmas ghost story, Dominic,
当我经检查首次发现这其中有一份托马斯·莫茅斯的《圣威廉传》，并且其次发现似乎没有其他已知抄本时，我感到无比高兴。它是用上好羊皮纸双栏书写，字体优美（出自一人或两人之手）。它保留了原本的木质封面，以前由皮带和插销固定。我将其年代判定在 1200 年之前不久。”所以，如果你喜欢鬼故事，尤其是维多利亚时代晚期到 20 世纪初的经典鬼故事，Sputter Viola 场景中的人们就会做出某种亡灵巫术的手势。是的，你确实做了。非常吓人。它唤起了圣诞鬼故事的精神，多米尼克，
even though we're recording this in the middle of June. That's great. Well, listen, if you love a ghost story, you will recognise there the prose of Montague Rhodes James, M.R. James, whose tales of ghosts and of horrific goings on usually in churches in East Anglia, they are surely the most chilling stories ever written. And he wrote that passage in 1896 and by the time of his death 40 years later he had established an international reputation, hadn't he Tom, as he was the Shakespeare of the ghost story, the Dickens, the Mozart of the horror story. I guess, I mean, his only conceivable contemporary rival for the title of the greatest horror
尽管我们是在六月中旬录制这期节目。太棒了。好吧，听着，如果你喜欢鬼故事，你就会在那里认出蒙塔古·罗兹·詹姆斯（Montague Rhodes James）的散文，即 M.R. 詹姆斯，他关于鬼魂和可怕事件的故事（通常发生在东盎格利亚的教堂里）绝对是有史以来写得最令人毛骨悚然的故事。他在 1896 年写下了那段话，到他 40 年后去世时，他在国际上树立了声誉，不是吗，汤姆？他是鬼故事界的莎士比亚，恐怖故事界的狄更斯和莫扎特。我想，我的意思是，当代唯一能与他争夺最伟大恐怖
story writer would have been H.P. Lovecraft in America. And Lovecraft was a huge admirer of M.R. James and wrote, Dr. James, for all his light touch, evokes fright and hideousness in their most shocking forms and will certainly stand as one of the few really creative masters in his darks and province. And I think that you in that reading really powerfully evoked that sense of fright and hideousness. Good. Essentially that's quite a boring passage, but my goodness, the chills that went down
故事作家称号的人，大概只有美国的 H.P. 洛夫克拉夫特（H.P. Lovecraft）。而洛夫克拉夫特是 M.R. 詹姆斯的狂热崇拜者，他曾写道：“詹姆斯博士尽管笔触轻松，却以最震撼的形式唤起了恐惧和狰狞，他必将作为其黑暗领域中少数真正的创造性大师之一永垂史册。”我认为你在刚才的朗读中确实有力地唤起了那种恐惧和狰狞的感觉。很好。本质上那是一段相当无聊的文字，但天哪，你读的时候，
the spine as you read it. That literally took about 30 takes for me to read that and get through it. So let's just talk about some of James's, before we get into today's subject, talk a little bit about some of James's stories and their characteristics and why you've chosen to kick off with him. So many of his stories, the really kind of canonical ones like digging up sacks and grounds and all of that kind of thing, they're often set in the kind of flat fields of East Anglia, which form this sort of brooding, slightly unearthly kind of landscape backdrop to the tales. And they're often about a church or a cathedral or a library
脊背发凉。我为了字正腔圆地读完这一段，字面意义上录了大约三十遍。那么，在我们进入今天的主题之前，让我们先来聊聊詹姆斯的一些故事、它们的特点，以及你为什么选择从他切入。他的许多故事，比如那种真正意义上的正统作品，比如在墓地和场地上挖土之类的事情，通常都以东盎格利亚平坦的田野为背景，这些田野为故事形成了一种阴郁、略带超凡脱俗的风景背景。而且它们通常围绕着一座教堂、一座大教堂、一个图书馆
or something like that. So the protagonist is often a scholar. So I was hoping to convey scholarship. You really did Dominic. Good, because I knew my own voice would not be up to it actually. No, you spoke like the incredible radio actor that you've become. Because you were in Sherlock and Co. weren't you? So you've played what was it, an irascible solicitor accused of killing a builder and now you've played an elderly scholar with something terrible to reveal.
或类似的地方展开。因此，主角往往是一个学者。所以我希望能传达出那种学术气息。你真的做到了，多米尼克。很好，因为我知道我自己的嗓音其实无法胜任。不，你说话就像你已经成为的那位出色的广播演员。因为你演过《神探夏洛克与公司》（Sherlock and Co.），对吧？所以你扮演过一个什么角色来着，一个被控谋杀建筑商的暴躁律师，现在你又扮演了一个有着可怕秘密要揭露的老学者。
Literally no role is beyond me Tom, I think it's fair to reveal. Literally no role is beyond me, Tom. I think it's fair to say. As well as being set in, say, an East Anglian cathedral city, as well as featuring a scholar with a kind of specialist knowledge of the ancient past, the plot will often revolve around the discovery of some antiquarian object. So it might be a whistle, you blow on the whistle and something terrible comes, or more commonly, an old forgotten manuscript. And the discovery of this kind of very ancient antiquarian object, whether it's a whistle or a manuscript, will conjure up from the grave some ancient unspeakable horror. And a huge part of the horror is that this ancient horror is now unleashed on the modern world. And all those elements are present in the
说实话，没有任何角色是我驾驭不了的，汤姆，我觉得可以这么说。字面意义上没有任何角色是我驾驭不了的，汤姆。我觉得这么说并不过分。除了以东盎格利亚的大教堂城市等为背景，除了以一个对古代历史有着专业知识的学者为主角之外，情节往往围绕着某个古物的发现展开。比如可能是一个哨子，你吹一下哨子，就会有可怕的事情发生；或者更常见的是，一本被遗忘的古老手稿。而这种非常古老的古物的发现（无论是哨子还是手稿），都会从坟墓中唤出某种古老的、不可名状的恐怖。而这种恐怖中极重要的一部分，就是这种古老的恐怖现在被释放到了现代世界。而所有这些元素都存在于
book from which that passage you so magnificently read comes from. And it's a book called The Life and Miracles of St. William of Norwich. But Dominic, here's the thing. That book is not a work of fiction. What a bone shell. It's actually a real book. It a work of fiction. What a bullsh-t. It's actually a real book. It's a factual book. It's a real book. So when James wrote horror stories about scholars discovering ancient manuscripts and being
你刚才以无比宏伟的方式朗读的那段文字所出自的书籍中。这本书叫做《诺维奇的圣威廉的生平与神迹》（The Life and Miracles of St. William of Norwich）。但是，多米尼克，问题来了。这本书并不是一部虚构作品。简直是个重磅炸弹。它其实是一本真实的。一本虚构作品。简直是个扯—。这其实是一本真实的。它是一本纪实书籍。它是一本真实的书。所以，当詹姆斯写下关于学者们发现古代手稿，并被
haunted by the terrors conjured up from the grave that he finds in these manuscripts, I mean, he knew whereof he spoke because he was himself a very distinguished scholar. And over the course of his career, he served as director of the Fitzwilliam Museum in Cambridge, the provost of King's College, also in Cambridge, and the vice chancellor of Cambridge University, also in Cambridge. So there's an East Anglian theme developing there. He also discovered a manuscript fragment that led to the discovery in Barry St Edmunds, also in East Anglia, of the graves of various 12th century abbots. And there's some very eerie photos showing the opened tombs and
这些手稿中从坟墓里召唤出来的恐怖所困扰的恐怖故事时，我的意思是，他是心知肚明的，因为他本人就是一位杰出的学者。在他的职业生涯中，他曾担任剑桥菲茨威廉博物馆（Fitzwilliam Museum）馆长、同样在剑桥的国王学院院长，以及剑桥大学副校长。所以那里正在发展一个东盎格利亚的主题。他还发现了一个手稿碎片，这促使人们在同样位于东盎格利亚的巴里圣埃德蒙兹（Barry St Edmunds）发现了多位 12 世纪修道院长的坟墓。有一些非常诡异的照片显示了打开的陵墓和
the skeletons of the abbots lying in them. And also, as described in the passage that you read so brilliantly, he sourced a large number of medieval manuscripts for the Cambridge University Library. And his book, The Life and Miracles of St. William of Norwich, is about one of those manuscripts. And it describes not just the murder of a child, but the birth of a horror, I think, infinitely greater than any of those that James portrayed in his ghost stories and which still stalks the world to this day. And there's a little clue, isn't there? It's the theme of that manuscript, The Life of
躺在里面的修道院长的骨骼。而且，正如你精彩朗读的那段文字中所描述的那样，他为剑桥大学图书馆搜集了大量的文艺复兴或中世纪手稿。他的书《诺维奇的圣威廉的生平与神迹》就是关于其中一本手稿的。它不仅描述了一个儿童的谋杀案，还描述了一个恐怖的诞生，我认为这个恐怖比詹姆斯在他的鬼故事中描绘的任何恐怖都要无限巨大，而且它至今仍在世界上徘徊。这里有一个小线索，不是吗？那就是那份手稿的主题，《诺维奇圣威廉的生平与
Miracles of St. William of Norwich, in a story that James wrote in 1895. And that story is called Lost Hearts. So tell us a bit about that story. This is presumably while he's preparing and maybe editing the book on St. William that comes out the year later. It's a very short story. So you can access it online. It will take you about 10 minutes to read. And it describes a young orphan boy who's age 12, who is invited to stay with his much older cousin, who is a very distinguished scholar of ancient cults, particularly in late antiquity. And he stays there and he starts to see the ghosts of two children. And when he sees them up close, he realizes that these children have had their
神迹》，它出现在詹姆斯于 1895 年写的一个故事中。那个故事叫做《失落的心》（Lost Hearts）。那么给我们讲讲那个故事吧。这大概是在他准备并可能编辑第二年出版的关于圣威廉的书的时候。这是一个非常短的故事。所以你可以在网上找到它。读完它大约需要 10 分钟。它描述了一个 12 岁的年轻孤儿男孩，他应邀去和比他大得多的表哥住在一起，这位表哥是一位非常杰出的古代邪教学者，尤其是晚期古代邪教。他住在那里，开始看到两个小孩的鬼魂。当他近距离看到他们时，他意识到这些孩子的
hearts cut out, that their chests have been smashed open and their hearts removed. And so when the summons comes one evening from his cousin to come to him late at night and before the cousin has arrived, the little boy goes there early and he finds us a brassiere there and an old silver gilt cup full of what looks to be red wine, but might be something else. And his cousin sprinkling some incense on the brassiere from a round silver box. You know, the implication is this isn't great. The prospects aren't good for him. This isn't going to be a fun evening.
心脏被挖出来了，他们的胸膛被砸开，心脏被取走了。因此，当一天晚上他表哥召唤他深夜前去，而在表哥到达之前，小男孩提前去了那里，他在那里发现了一个火盆和一个装满了看起来像是红葡萄酒、但也可能是别的东西的旧镀银杯子。他的表哥正从一个圆形的银盒子里把一些香撒在火盆上。你知道，这意味着情况不妙。他的前景不太好。这不会是一个愉快的夜晚。
So the theme of a ritualized child sacrifice was evidently much on James's mind as he was preparing the life and miracles of St. William of Norwich. And so with that kind of preview listeners may be wondering, well, what is this text about? Well, just to give some context, it was written in the second half of the 12th century. So as James said shortly before the year 1200, by a monk from Monmouth in Wales called Thomas, who sometime between 1146 and 1150, so the middle of the century, had joined the monastery in Norwich, which is in East Anglia, and this monastery was attached to the cathedral that had been built there in the wake of the Norman conquest. And the story that Thomas of Monmouth tells has
因此，当詹姆斯在准备《诺维奇的圣威廉的生平与神迹》时，仪式化儿童献祭的主题显然深深地留在了他的脑海中。因此，有了这样的前瞻，听众可能会想，那么，这篇文本讲的是什么呢？好吧，为了提供一些背景，它写于 12 世纪下半叶；正如詹姆斯所说，大约在 1200 年之前不久，由威尔士莫茅斯的名叫托马斯的修士所写，他在 1146 年至 1150 年之间的某个时候（也就是世纪中叶），加入了东盎格利亚诺维奇的修道院，这座修道院依附于诺曼征服后在那里建造的大教堂。托马斯·莫茅斯讲述的故事的
at its heart a murder. The date is March 1144, so almost a century after the Norman conquest. The setting for this murder is Thorpe Wood, which is a wooded stretch of the heathland that rises north of the city of Norwich, and Norwich is in the northeast of East Anglia. And the plot is centered around events that happen in Holy Week. So on the evening of Good Friday, according to Thomas, a fiery light suddenly flashed down from heaven and descended on the wood. And this strange phenomenon is witnessed by a nun who is the widow of a Norman aristocrat called the Lady Legada. And the Lady Legada and her various other nuns gaze out at this extraordinary phenomenon and they see that the light is continuing to blaze in the wood and it seems, and I quote Thomas
核心是一起谋杀案。日期是 1144 年 3 月，几乎是诺曼征服一个世纪之后。这起谋杀案的发生地点是索普森林（Thorpe Wood），这是一片林木茂密的荒地，位于诺维奇市北部的高地上，而诺维奇位于东盎格利亚的东北部。情节围绕着圣周（Holy Week）发生的事件展开。根据托马斯的说法，复活节星期五的晚上，一道炽热的光芒突然从天而降，落入树林。这个奇怪的现象被一位修女目睹了，她是诺曼贵族雷加达夫人（the Lady Legada）的遗孀。雷加达夫人和其他几位修女凝视着这个非同寻常的现象，她们看到光芒在树林中继续燃烧，并且似乎（我引用托马斯·莫茅斯的话）
of Monmouth, to divide into two rays which took the shape of a very long ladder extending from below into the sky to the eastward. So at dawn the next day, Lady Lagarda and various of her fellow sisters get up, it's Easter Saturday, but they head out into the woods to investigate. And they go to the place where they had seen the light rising and it turns out to be an oak tree. And they're hanging from one of the branches of the oak tree. Lady Lagarda discovers, and again I quote, a boy dressed in his jacket and shoes, his head shaved and punctured with countless stabs. And according to Thomas of Monmouth, various carrion birds, so ravens and so on, are circling around the body trying to feed on it, but they can't settle on the body. And so it seems that the body is being protected from desecration by some supernatural power.
分成了两条射线，形成了一架非常长的梯子，从下方向东延伸到天空中。所以在第二天黎明，雷加达夫人和她的几位同伴修女起床了，那是复活节星期六，但她们前往树林去调查。她们来到了她们看到光芒升起的地方，结果发现是一棵橡树。雷加达夫人发现（再次引用原话），在橡树的一根树枝上挂着一个穿着夹克和鞋子的男孩，他的头部被剃光，并且有无数刺伤。根据托马斯的说法，各种食腐鸟类（乌鸦等）正在尸体周围盘旋，试图吃掉它，但它们无法在尸体上栖息。因此，尸体似乎正受到某种超自然力量的保护，免遭亵渎。
Right. Legarda approaches the corpse. She and her sisters drive off the carrion birds. They pray over the body, and then again, I quote, commending the boy over to the care of his saviour, she returned home with her companions rejoicing. And people may think it's a bit odd to rejoice over the corpse of a boy who's hanging from a tree. She's rejoicing because she knows that the boy in some way must have been holy to God, and therefore presumably has been taken up to heaven. So
对。雷加达走近尸体。她和她的修女们赶走了食腐鸟类。她们在尸体旁祈祷，然后（再次引用原话）“将男孩托付给他的救世主照顾，她和同伴们欢欣鼓舞地回家了”。人们可能会觉得，为一棵树上挂着的男孩尸体欢欣鼓舞有点奇怪。她之所以高兴，是因为她知道这个男孩在某种程度上对上帝一定是神圣的，因此大概已经被接引到了天堂。所以
the corpse of the boy is left hanging from this tree as Lady Ligarda and her fellow nuns head off. And shortly afterwards, a forester called Henry de Sprouston rides into the wood. And he is looking for, not for poachers, but for people illegally harvesting timber, because there's quite a shortage of timber in East Anglia. Norwich is a boom town. He wants to make sure that people aren't illegally removing the timber. And in the forest, he finds a peasant who is removing timber. And clearly the peasant is anxious about being taken into custody. And so he says, you'd never believe it, over there, there's a boy hanging from a tree. And so Henry de Spouwsten is obviously distracted and he goes over to
当雷加达夫人和她的修女同伴们离开时，男孩的尸体被留在那棵树上。不久之后，一个名叫亨利·德·斯普罗克斯顿（Henry de Sprouston）的护林员骑马进入树林。他在寻找的不是偷猎者，而是非法砍伐木材的人，因为东盎格利亚非常缺木材。诺维奇是一个繁荣的城镇。他想确保人们没有非法砍伐木材。在森林里，他发现了一个正在砍伐木材的农民。显然，这个农民很担心被拘留。于是他说：“你绝对想不到，那边树上挂着一个男孩。”所以亨利·德·斯普罗克斯顿显然被转移了注意力，他走过去
where the body is and he investigates the corpse and he finds that the boy, in addition to being stabbed, has been very, very brutally gagged with a piece of rope with knots in it. So kind of the, as the rope has been tightened in his mouth, the knots have gouged into the back of the head. So very horrible. Jesus. So do we know who the boy was? Well, De Sproustain investigates this and it doesn't take long for him to identify the boy and it turns out to be an apprentice leather worker called William. And this apprentice leather worker is 12 years old. So like the boy in MR James's story who has the sinister
查看尸体，他发现除了被刺伤之外，这个男孩还被一根带结的粗绳子非常非常残酷地塞住了嘴。随着绳子在他的嘴里勒紧，绳结深深地陷入了脑后。非常可怕。天哪。那么我们知道这个男孩是谁吗？嗯，德·斯普罗克斯顿对此进行了调查，没花多久他就认出了这个男孩，结果发现他是一个名叫威廉的学徒皮革工。这个皮革工学徒今年 12 岁。就像 M.R. 詹姆斯故事里那个有着阴险
cousin. Yeah. In lost hearts. William, he's been working in Norwich. Originally he'd come from the countryside. This doesn't mean that he was an uneducated peasant. It seems that as well as his native English, he spoke of a smattering of French and maybe even a bit of Latin. And there's a brilliant study of, of this case, the murder of William of Norwich by
表哥的男孩一样。是的。在《失落的心》中。威廉一直在诺维奇工作。他最初来自乡下。这并不意味着他是一个没受过教育的农民。除了他的母语英语之外，他似乎还懂一点法语，甚至可能懂一点拉丁语。有一项关于威廉之死这起案件的出色研究，
E.M. Rose. And she's done a lot of research into the possible background of William, and she suggests that his father may well have been a moneyer. So that's a very kind of upwardly mobile job for someone to have. And we know for sure that his uncle was a priest because it's this priest, Godwin, who according to Thomas of Monmouth, formally identifies the body. And by this point, when Godwin comes to identify the body, William has already been buried out in the woods, in unconsecrated ground, and they exhumed the body. And when the body is brought out, an absolute miracle.
作者是 E.M. 罗斯（E.M. Rose）。她对威廉可能的背景做了大量研究，她指出他的父亲很可能是个铸币工。对于某人来说，这是一份阶层上升空间很大的工作。我们确切地知道他的叔叔是一名神父，因为根据托马斯的说法，正是这位名叫戈德温（Godwin）的神父正式辨认了尸体。到了这个时候，当戈德温来辨认尸体时，威廉已经被埋在树林里未成圣的土地上了，他们把尸体掘了出来。当尸体被抬出来时，一个绝对的奇迹发生了。
Though so many days had passed by since the time when they suspected he had been put to death, yet there was absolutely no bad smell perceptible. But what seemed more deserving, their wonder was that though there was never a flower there nor any sweet smelling herb growing there about, yet there the perfume of spring flowers and fragrant herbs was wafted to the nostrils of all present. So what this suggests is that the body is intact, and an intact body is an absolutely certain signifier of a kind of saintly status. So you think of St Cuthbert buried in Durham Cathedral after many, many wanderings around the northeast. the intact nature of St Cuthbert's body is the marker of his sanctity.
尽管距离他们怀疑他被处决的时间已经过去了许多天，但根本闻不到任何恶臭。但更让他们惊奇的是，尽管那里从来没有花，也没有任何芳香的草本植物生长在附近，但春花的芳香和芬芳的草本植物的气味却飘到了在场所有人的鼻孔里。这说明尸体是完好无损的，而一具完好的尸体是某种圣洁身份的绝对确凿标志。所以你想想在东北部流落很多很多地方之后被埋在达勒姆大教堂（Durham Cathedral）的圣卡斯伯特（St Cuthbert）。圣卡斯伯特尸体的完好本质就是他圣洁的标志。
And so it seems that William likewise is one of the blessed who has been gathered up into the arms of God. So it's a very, very mysterious case. So very mysterious case, Tom, who was the killer? Or was there more than one killer? Was it a collective thing thing or ritualistic thing. Why the gag and why so many stab wounds why was william this boy even in the wood in the first place.
因此，威廉似乎同样是被接入上帝怀抱的有福之人之一。所以这是一个非常非常神秘的案子。那么一个非常神秘的案子，汤姆，凶手是谁？或者说凶手不止一个？这是一场集体作案还是仪式性行为？为什么要塞住嘴，为什么有那么多刺伤，威廉这个男孩一开始为什么会在树林里？
If his father is a is a money from norwich or was he killed in norwich and then his body moved to the water was he taken to the wood to be killed well a lot of mysteries there Poirot but first of all why don't we put this into the its historical context because i suspect that will be really important because we are in the anarchy so 1144 and this is the war between Matilda Henry the first's daughter, and her what, cousin? Stephen, Stephen of Blois, who is a terrible king. Well, yeah, I mean, he's busy fighting a civil war and it goes on for ages. So actually from 1138 to 1153. So in 1144, we're absolutely bang in the middle of it. And it's famously
如果他的父亲是诺维奇的铸币工，还是他在诺维奇被杀然后尸体被运到了水边？他是被带到树林里杀害的吗？这里有太多的谜团了，大侦探波洛，但首先，我们为什么不把它放在历史背景中呢？因为我怀疑这非常重要，因为我们正处于“无政府时期”（the Anarchy）——也就是 1144 年，这是玛蒂尔达（Matilda，亨利一世的女儿）与她的什么人——表哥？——斯蒂芬（Stephen of Blois，布卢瓦的斯蒂芬）之间的战争，他是一个糟糕的国王。嗯，是的，我的意思是，他忙着打一场内战，而且持续了很长时间。所以实际上从 1138 年到 1153 年。所以在 1144 年，我们正处在正中央。它被彼得伯勒（Peterborough，距离诺维奇大约 60 英里，非常处于东盎格利亚风暴的中心）的一位编年史家著名地
described by chronicler in Peterborough, which is about 60 miles from Norwich, so very much in the eye of the East Anglian storm, as a time when Christ and his saints sleep. So we can be fairly confident that when this chronicler in Peterborough, who is updating the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, which is still going at this point, even after 1066. And he's describing how armed gangs of thugs are roaming the countryside, targeting anyone who might have money, robbing them, killing them. He is definitely describing conditions that prevailed in the countryside around both Norwich and Peterborough. And just to give a passage from the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle on the horrors of the anarchy,
描述为“基督和他的圣徒们在睡觉”的时期。因此我们可以相当有把握地认为，当彼得伯勒这位正在更新《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》（Anglo-Saxon Chronicle，即使在 1066 年之后仍在继续）的编年史家，描述武装暴徒帮派如何在乡村游荡、将任何可能有钱的人作为目标、抢劫他们、杀死他们时，他绝对是在描述诺维奇和彼得伯勒周围乡村普遍存在的状况。为了引用《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中关于无政府时期恐怖景象的一段话：
no martyrs were ever tortured as these victims, so the victims of the robbers were. They were hung by the thumbs or by the head, and corselets were hung on their feet. Notted ropes were put round their heads and twisted till they penetrated to the brains. I neither can nor may tell all the wounds and agonies which they inflicted on the wretched men of this land." So what do you make of that, Hastings? Yes, that I think is very telling, isn't it? So, these thugs have a particular modus operandi and young William, I guess, is he the kind of, I mean, he's a boy, he's from's from you said an upwardly mobile family, he's working
没有哪个烈士遭受过如这些受害者（即强盗的受害者）那般残酷的折磨。他们被大拇指或头部悬挂着，脚上挂着胸甲。带结的绳子套在头上扭转，直到刺入大脑。我既不能也不会讲述他们加诸这片土地上不幸之人的所有创伤和痛苦。”黑斯廷斯，你对此作何感想？是的，我认为这很有说明意义，不是吗？所以，这些暴徒有特定的作案手法，年轻的威廉，我猜，他是不是那种……我的意思是，他是个男孩，正如你所说，他来自一个阶层不断上升的家庭，他作为学徒或类似身份在工作，是这样吗？是的，所以他的钱包里可能叮当作响地装着一些钱。那么他难道不是这些无赖、恶棍的明显目标吗？事实上，被塞住嘴、被吊起来、大拇指或头部悬挂、脚上挂着胸甲、他们遭受了折磨，等等等等。我的意思是，这看起来他只是无政府时期的一个标准受害者，是席卷英格兰的这种土匪浪潮的牺牲品，不是吗？你可能会这么想，但这必须指出，这并不是最终受到青睐的解释，而且这肯定不是托马斯·莫茅斯的解释，
as an apprentice or something like that, is that right? Yeah, so he might have a bit of money jingling in his purse. So would he not be an obvious target for these ne'er-do-wells, these ruffians, and in fact the gag, the hanging, hung by the thumbs or by the head, corsets on the feet, they were tortured, blah blah blah, blah blah blah. I mean that just looks like he's a standard victim of the anarchy, of this kind of wave of banditry that's swept across England, no? You might think that, but it has to be said, this is not the explanation that ultimately came to be favoured and it's certainly not the explanation that Thomas of Monmouth, whose
我们在这集节目中必须对他的可靠性进行压力测试。这不是他得出的结论。原因在于戈德温和威廉家里的其他人并不认为威廉是土匪和强盗的受害者。他们认为威廉的谋杀犯是更加阴险的人物。戈德温认为这些人是字面意义上的恶魔般邪恶的人物，他们不住在穷旅行者会被抓获并折磨至死的路上，而是令人毛骨悚然地住在诺维奇市内。噢，这太让人毛骨悚然了。那么这些人是谁？他们在诺维奇市内究竟在干什么？噢，这太让人毛骨悚然了。那么这些人是谁？他们在诺维奇在干什么？好吧，先交代一下背景。
reliability we will have to stress test over the course of this episode. It's not the conclusion that he comes to. And the reason for that is that Godwin and the rest of William's family, they do not think that William has been the victim of bandits and robbers. They come to identify Williams murderers as even more sinister figures. Men who Godwin thinks of as figures of literally diabolical evil, who live not out on the roads where poor travelers can be captured and tortured to death, but chillingly within Norwich itself. Ooh, that is chilling. So who are these people and what are they doing within Norwich itself. Oh, that is chilling. So who are these people and what are they doing in Norwich? Okay, some setting first.
所以首先是诺维奇，到了这个时候，它是英格兰第二大城市，虽然其实也算不上什么大城市，人口可能在 5,000 人左右。但它之所以发展起来，是因为它是农作物非常丰富的地区的中心。土壤非常肥沃，有大量的羊，所以有羊毛；有牛，所以有皮革和牛肉等等。它通过河流非常便利地与海洋相连。所以它确实处于有利地位。而且像英格兰许多关键地方一样，它现在被一座用石头建造的巨大城堡以及一座始建于 1096 年的大教堂所主导，这是有史以来建造的最令人印象深刻的诺曼教会结构之一。所有这些都是诺维奇有多么
So Norwich first of all, by this point, it's the second largest city in England, which isn't to say much actually, population probably around 5,000 people. But it's grown because it's the centre of a region that's very rich in crops. Soil is very fertile, lots of sheep, so wool, there's cattle, so hides and beef and so on. And it's linked very conveniently by rivers to the sea. So it's in pole position really. And like so many key places in England, it is now dominated by a vast castle built out of stone and also by a cathedral that was begun in 1096 and it's one of the most impressive Norman ecclesiastical structures ever built. So these are all markers of how
重要的标志，但诺维奇的重要性和繁荣还有另一个标志，那就是城里存在着一个犹太人社区。犹太人是在诺曼征服后首次来到英格兰的，但他们真正来到诺维奇，是在威廉被谋杀前的一代人左右。他们在诺维奇从事金融工作、担任铸币工、医生、学者、工匠，作为一个社区，他们非常非常成功。在整个英格兰，向英国国库交纳税款比诺维奇更多的犹太人社区只有伦敦。因此，深陷与表哥玛蒂尔达内战的斯蒂芬基本上将东盎格利亚控制在手中，他需要钱来打内战。
significant Norwich is, but there is another marker of Norwich's importance and prosperity and that is the presence within the city of a community of Jews. And Jews had first come to England after the Norman Conquest, but they'd come to Norwich really only a generation before the murder of William. And they work in Norwich in finance, as moneyers, as doctors, as scholars, as artisans, and as a community, they're very, very successful. And across England, the only community of Jews that pay more tax to the royal exchequer than Norwich is London. And so Stephen, embroiled in this civil war with his cousin Matilda, he essentially has East Anglia under his control, and he needs money to fight the civil war.
所以他喜欢犹太人。我的意思是，他认为他们太棒了。他们为他赚了很多钱并交了税，这样他就可以继续打仗。然而在历史上，在混乱时期赚大钱的人，也往往是那些因为与邻居不同而已经受到怀疑的人。这样的人往往会招致怨恨、阴谋论、敌意，正如我们所知，还有暴力。诺维奇的犹太人现在也是这种情况吗？嗯，正如你所说，他们不受欢迎有明显的原因。另一个原因是他们与诺曼人有联系，
And so he loves the Jews. I mean, he thinks they're great. They're making him lots of money and giving him taxes and so he can carry on fighting. And yet throughout history, people who make a lot of money in a time of chaos, also people who are already regarded with suspicion because they are different from their neighbors. Such people often tend to incur resentment, conspiracy theories, hostility, and as we know, violence. And is that the case at this point with the Jews of Norwich? Well, as you say, there are obvious reasons for their unpopularity. Another is that they are associated with the Normans,
因此他们被被殖民的人民与他们的殖民者联系在一起。这可能与阿迪·阿明（Idi Amin）统治下的乌干达人看待亚洲人的方式有某种相似之处。那些被英国人带过来的亚洲人。但显然，诺维奇是一个基督教城市，因此存在着根深蒂固的神学原因，这些原因一直追溯到基督教的最初发端，解释了为什么基督会对犹太人产生负面刻板印象。因此，他们在基督徒眼中被视为异类，他们故意把自己与普遍的（在希腊语中是“天主教”的）基督灵魂社区隔离开来。这显然是敌意的根源。人们认为他们对基督徒有着强烈的恶意，因此
and so they are associated by colonized people with their colonizers. And there might be a kind of parallel with the way that Asians were regarded in Idi Amin's Uganda. Asians who'd been brought over by the British. But obviously, Norwich is a Christian city, and so there are deeply rooted theological reasons which go all the way back to the very beginnings of Christianity as to why Christians might have negative stereotypes of Jews. So they are viewed by Christians as aliens who have willfully shut themselves off from the universal, which in Greek is Catholic, community of Christian souls. So that's an obvious cause of hostility. They are believed to have an intense malevolence towards Christians, so
他们被指责为基督在十字架上受难的希腊罪魁祸首。此外，由于希罗德是一个犹太人，而希罗德是试图杀死耶稣时在伯利恒发起屠杀无辜者的人，在 12 世纪期间，无辜者越来越多地被塑造成基督徒，因此有一种感觉，即犹太人对儿童有着特殊的敌意。还有一种更广泛的感觉，即他们被上帝诅咒了，他们受到魔鬼的青睐，因为他们杀害了弥赛亚而被驱逐流亡，他们被驱逐出自己的祖国，并且本质上他们的额头上带有该隐的印记。
they are blamed for the sufferings of Christ on the cross. They are also, because Herod was a Jew, and Herod is the man who launches the massacre of the innocents in Bethlehem when he's trying to kill Jesus. The innocents over the course of the 12th century are increasingly being cast as Christians, and so there's a sense that Jews have a particular animus against children. And there is a broader feeling that they have been cursed by God, that they're favored by the devil, that they've been driven into exile because they slew the Messiah, that they've been exiled from their homeland, and that essentially they kind of bear the mark of Cain on their brows.
因此，如果基督徒愿意的话，有一整套非常消极的刻板印象可供他们借鉴。但你问，诺维奇此时基督徒和犹太人的关系是否一直充满敌意？绝对不是。因为尽管存在对犹太人的普遍敌意潜流，但大体上，教会和基督教国王在对待犹太人的态度上，都受到几个世纪以来的相对（我强调“相对”这个词）宽容的影响。例如，教皇一直雇用犹太人。他们一直是罗马和教皇统治土地上犹太人的保护人。所以在公元 598 年，
So there's a whole swirl of very negative stereotypes that Christians can draw on if they want to. But you ask, you know, are relations between Christians and Jews in Norwich at this time unremittingly hostile? Absolutely, they're not. Because even though there are kind of currents of popular hostility to Jews, by and large, both the church and Christian kings are influenced in their attitude to Jews by centuries of relative, and I emphasize the word relative tolerance. So the popes, for instance, have always employed Jews. They've always served as the patron of Jews in Rome and the lands ruled by the popes. So in 598,
格里高利一世（Gregory the First, Gregory the Great）曾下令，犹太人及其社区绝不能遭受其权利的侵犯。法兰克国王（即墨洛温王朝）、查理曼大帝及其继承人都承认他们是一个拥有自己法律、自己的宗教（religio）、与上帝有自己关系的民族。例如，主教们不仅可以以一种勉强的宽容来看待犹太人，甚至可以带着一种钦佩之情。因此，在 1084 年莱茵河畔的施派尔（Speyer），一位主教下令，犹太人在他的教区存在是该教区的荣誉。我的意思是，大多数主教不会走得那么远，但这显然为拉丁基督教世界中的一种生活方式（modus vivendi）奠定了基础，使
Gregory the First, Gregory the Great had decreed that the Jews in their communities were in no way to suffer a violation of their rights. The Frankish kings, so the Merovingians, Charlemagne and his heirs had recognized them as a people with their own law, their own religio, their own kind of relationship to God. And it's possible for, say, bishops to view Jews not just with a kind of grudging toleration, but with almost a sense of admiration. So in 1084 in Speyer on the Rhine, a bishop decrees that the presence of Jews in his diocese does it honor. I mean, most bishops don't go that far, but there is clearly a basis there for a kind of modus vivendi in Latin Christendom that enables
犹太社区得以繁荣发展，这基本上就是他们几个世纪以来一直在做的事情。在中世纪早期，对犹太人并没有那种暴力和迫害的情绪。当然在英格兰，12 世纪对于定居那里的犹太人来说是一个相当和平的时期。没有真正的暴力爆发。肯定也没有皇室或教会的迫害。我认为诺维奇的犹太人，远没有让诺维奇的人民觉得“哦，他们是个威胁”，我认为他们——好吧，他们当然被城市当局承认是其成功的关键要素。诺维奇市镇当局传达的信息我想会是：多元化是诺维奇的力量之源。
Jewish communities to thrive, which is essentially what they have done for centuries. There isn't a kind of a mood of violence and persecution in the kind of the early Middle Ages towards the Jews. And certainly in England, the 12th century is a pretty peaceful period for the Jews who settled there. There are no real outbreaks of violence. There's certainly no royal or ecclesiastical persecution. And I think the Jews of Norwich, far from people in Norwich thinking, oh, they're a menace, I think they're, well, they're certainly acknowledged by the city authorities as a key ingredient to its success. Diversity is Norwich's strength, I think, would be the message of the Norwich town authorities.
那么，在什么时间点——剧透预警，犹太人将为这起谋杀案背锅？在什么时间点怀疑的矛头开始指向犹太人？有多少人会相信，你觉得？似乎是威廉的家人指指点点的。因此，托马斯·莫茅斯说，他的母亲从乡下来到诺维奇，被告知威廉曾被提供了一份厨师的工作，并去诺维奇的一位主要犹太人家里谈论此事，然后就在这个犹太人家里消失了，再也没有被看到过。我的意思是，这有多可靠，我们稍后会讨论。但真正推动指控的人似乎是神职人员戈德温，也就是威廉的叔叔。他是那个把
So, at what point, I mean big spoiler alert, the Jews are going to get blamed for this murder. At what point does the finger of blame start to point towards the Jews and how many people believe it, would you say? It seems to be William's family who point the finger. So Thomas of Monmouth says that his mother comes from the country into Norwich and is told that William had been offered a job as a cook and had gone to a house of one of the leading Jews in Norwich to talk about it and had vanished into this Jews house and was never seen again. I mean, how reliable that is, we will discuss later. But the person who really seems to push the accusation is this priest Godwin, so William's uncle. He's the guy who takes
案件带到诺维奇主教那里并说“是犹太人集体杀害了我的侄子”的人。然后主教把这个案子带给当地的治安官，一个名叫约翰·迪谢尼（John Duchesne）的人。约翰·迪谢尼说：“这太荒谬了。这简直是……我的意思是，纯属无稽之谈。”他不仅拒绝了这个指控，而且还积极协助犹太人。首先，他告诉犹太人：“如果主教试图对你们提起诉讼，不要理会它。作为非基督徒，你们不属于教会法庭的管辖范围。”然后他将他们置于诺维奇城堡的直接保护之下。所以在那里他们实际上是绝对安全的。我想
the case to the Bishop of Norridge and says, it's the Jews collectively who have killed my nephew. And so the bishop then takes this case to the local sheriff, a man called John Duchesne. And John Duchesne says, this is ridiculous. This is, I mean, you have absolute nonsense. And not only does he reject the accusation, but he actively assists the Jews. So first he tells the Jews, if the bishop tries to launch prosecution against you, ignore it. As non-Christians, you are not under the remit of the ecclesiastical courts. And then he takes them under his direct protection in Norwich Castle. So there they are effectively completely secure. And I think
他会认为这些针对犹太人的指控是不大可能的，这是可以理解的，特别是这些指控来自神父戈德温，他曾去过树林并看到了发现威廉尸体的地方。我猜迪谢尼可能在想两件事。我的意思是，我们并不确切知道，但这很有可能。所以我怀疑迪谢尼要么认为这是威廉家人试图向犹太人勒索钱财的一种尝试——你指控他们，然后他们试图基本上通过花钱让原告消停；或者我认为可能有一个更黑暗的原因，那就是我们被告知的一件我们可以绝对确信的事情，那就是威廉被发现挂在一棵树上，因为托马斯·莫茅斯他相当不小心地
it's understandable that he should have thought these accusations against the Jews are improbable, particularly coming as they do from this priest Godwin who had gone out into the wood and had seen the place where William had been found dead. And I guess that Duchesne is thinking possibly two things. I mean, we don't know for sure, but it's likely. So I suspect that Duchesne thinks either this is an attempt by William's family to extort money from the Jews. You accuse them and they try and basically buy the accusers off. Or I think there's possibly a darker reason, which is the one thing we're told that I think we can absolutely rely on is that William is found hanging from a tree because Thomas of Monmouth, he rather lets
说漏嘴了。这不是他详细阐述的细节。因此，可能存在这样一种可能性，即威廉是自杀的。（你知道，他是一个独自在城市的年轻男孩。你可以想象出他可能想要自杀的任何原因。）对于基督徒来说，尤其是对于神职人员来说，一个把自己挂在树上的人，会立即让人联想到背叛了基督然后自杀的犹太（Judas）。在教会看来，正是这一点将自杀标记为一种犯罪。虽然这无法解释为什么被塞住嘴，而且这与我发现非常有说服力的观点（即这是无政府时期该地区许多暴徒的作案手法）略有冲突。难道这不是最简单的解释吗？
it slip. It's not a detail that he dwells on. And so there might be a possibility that William had hung himself. You know, he's a young boy alone in the city. You could think of any number of reasons why he might have wanted to kill himself. And a person who hangs himself from a tree for Christians, and certainly for a priest, would immediately conjure up thoughts of Judas who betrayed Christ and then hung himself. And it's this that marks suicide out as a crime in the opinion of the church. Although that wouldn't explain the gag and it slightly, it conflicts with the idea, which I find very persuasive that this is a modus operandi of lots of thugs in the area during the anarchy. Is that not the simplest?
我认为这是最简单的，但迪谢尼完全不相信这些说法的可能性是存在的。我猜因为这与犹太（Judas）有联系，这可能就是让（你可以想象）神父戈德温感到担忧的原因。所以他开始考虑犹太人，然后他想，好吧，也许真是犹太人干的。我们无法确切知道。我们相隔太远了。托马斯·莫茅斯的叙述是我们仅有的叙述。正如我们所看到的，我们无法百分之百地依赖它。但我猜迪谢尼对“犹太人杀害了诺维奇的威廉”这一观点持怀疑态度的主要原因是：他们为什么要这么做？我的意思是，他们有什么可以想象的理由这样做呢？因此，我认为并不奇怪，首先在接下来的几周、几个月
I think that is the simplest, but it is possible that Duchesne doesn't trust the accounts at all. And I guess that because there's association with Judas, that might be what puts, you know, you could imagine Godwin the priest worrying about this. And so he starts thinking about the Jews and then he thinks, well, maybe the Jews did. We can't know for sure. We're at such a distance. Thomas of Monmouth's account is the only one we have. And as we'll see, we can't 100% rely on it. But I guess that the chief reason why de Chesney would be skeptical about the idea that the Jews had killed William of Norwich is why would they have done it? I mean, what conceivable reason would they have had for doing it? And so it's not surprising, I think, that first in the weeks and then
、甚至几年里，在发现威廉尸体之后，没有任何关于这起谋杀案的严肃调查，当然也没有起诉。正如你所说，时局动荡。威廉死时的环境很晦暗，当时在东盎格利亚的田野和树林里有很多人惨死。我认为城市当局普遍有一种感觉，即威廉的家人对犹太人提出的指控是荒谬的。但是，汤姆，六年之后，在诺维奇的威廉死后六年，一切都变了，不是吗？一片阴影笼罩了诺维奇的犹太人，而这片阴影
in the months and then the years that follow the discovery of William's corpse, there isn't any serious investigation into the murder and certainly there is no prosecution. And as you say, the times are evil. The circumstances of William's death are murky and there are lots of people who are dying horribly in the fields and woods of East Anglia at this time. And I think that there's a general feeling on the part of the town authorities that the accusations that William's family have brought against the Jews are ridiculous. But then, Tom, six years later, six years after the death of William of Norwich, everything changes, doesn't it? A shadow falls across the Jews of Norwich and this is a shadow
一直延伸到巴勒斯坦。我们将在中场休息后继续讲述这个故事。中场休息之后。让细心的读者在这里观察到，上帝的审判是何等的公正，他是如何当之无愧地施加报应的：那个以邪恶之手诱骗基督徒进入其房屋并将其杀死，杀死后将其抛入树林，并将其暴露给狗和鸟的犹太人。这个人同样被诱骗出自己的房屋，在树林里被基督徒杀害，并且以完全相同的方式被留在露天，任由狗和鸟撕碎。这就是托马斯·莫茅斯，他在报道 1150 年发生的两次轰动性的审判。其中一次在诺维奇，另一次在伦敦
that stretches all the way from Palestine. And we'll pick up on that story after the break. after the break. Let the careful reader here observe how just was the judgment of God, and how worthily he dealt out retribution, in that the Jew, who with wicked hands had enticed a Christian into his house and killed him, when he had killed him, had flung him into a wood, and there had exposed him to the dogs and the birds. This same man was enticed out of his own house, was killed by the hands of Christians in a wood, and in exactly the same way was left in the open air and exposed to be torn to pieces by dogs and birds. So that was Thomas of Monmouth and he is reporting on two sensational trials that took place in 1150. One of them was in Norwich and the other one was in London
由国王斯蒂芬亲自主持，因为在诺维奇郊外的某个区又发现了一具谋杀受害者的尸体。但这一次，汤姆，受害者不是基督徒，而是一个犹太人。这到底是怎么回事？没错，而且不仅是随便一个犹太人，根据托马斯·莫茅斯的说法，他正是六年前策划谋杀 12 岁基督教徒学徒威廉的幕后主谋。所以这就是那个犹太人，据说威廉曾在他的家里消失，再也没有被任何基督徒灵魂看到过。这个被托马斯命名为埃利泽（Eliezer）的犹太人，在诺维奇郊外的道路上被一名骑士杀害
and they were presided over by King Stephen himself because a second murder victim had been found in a ward outside Norwich. But this time Tom, it was not a Christian, it was a Jew. So what's going on? That's right, and not just any Jew, but the man who, according to Thomas of Monmouth, at any rate had masterminded the murder six years previously of the 12-year-old Christian apprentice, William. And so this was the Jew into whose house supposedly William had vanished never to be seen again by any Christian soul. And the Jew who is named by Thomas as Eliezer had been killed out on the roads beyond Norwich by a knight
而且由斯蒂芬国王亲自主持，因为在诺里奇城外的一个病房里又发现了一名谋杀受害者。但这一次，汤姆，受害者不是基督徒，而是一名犹太人。那么这到底是怎么回事？没错，而且不仅是一个普通的犹太人，根据托马斯·オブ·蒙茅斯的说法，正是这个人在六年前策划了谋杀12岁基督徒学徒威廉的案件。所以这就是那个威廉据说曾消失在他家里、再也没有被任何基督徒灵魂看到的犹太人。而被托马斯命名为埃利泽的犹太人，则是在诺里奇郊外的道路上被一名骑士杀害的
named Sir Simon de Novas, who was very deeply in debt to Eliezer and couldn't pay him back. And the case is absolutely open and shut. And Stephen, who is very anxious to signal his support for the Jewish community, he is very keen on the taxes that they pay him. He's keen to make an example of de Novas, you know, bang him up, hang him, whatever. Let's, let's convict this guy. But even though Stephen is basically set on finding De Novas guilty, this isn't what happens because the longer the trials go on, the harder it becomes for Stephen to convict De Novas. And finally, the trial in London, which follows the trial in Norwich, basically he gives up on the whole thing.
名叫西蒙·德·诺瓦斯（Sir Simon de Novas），他深陷对埃利泽的巨额债务，根本无力偿还。而且这个案子绝对是铁证如山。斯蒂芬非常急于向犹太社群表态支持，他很看重犹太人向他缴纳的税款。他很想拿德·诺瓦斯杀鸡儆猴，你知道的，把他关起来、绞死，随便怎么都行。总之定这个家伙的罪吧。然而，尽管斯蒂芬基本上已经铁了心要判德·诺瓦斯有罪，但事情并没有这样发展，因为审判持续得越久，斯蒂芬想给德·诺瓦斯定罪就变得越发困难。最后，继诺里奇的审判之后的伦敦审判，基本上让他彻底放弃了这整桩案件。
And he says, we have been fatigued by a good deal of discourse today, and yet have some business which keeps us. We are unable therefore to give the requisite attention to so weighty a matter. So in other words, he's basically washing his hands of it. He's saying, I don't have time for all this. De Novas isn't, he's not acquitted, but he's able to go free and he's never punished for the murder of Eliaza, which he undoubtedly committed. I mean, it's a slightly comical verdict from Stephen that, you know, we've run out of time and I can't be bothered. And yet, gross injustice. I mean, if you're the family of this guy, Eliaza, you're gutted about this. This De Novas has got away with it, it's got free.
他说：我们今天已经被大量的讨论弄得精疲力竭，手头还有一些事务在等着我们。因此，我们无法对如此重大之事的投入必要的关注。换句话说，他基本上是对此撒手不管了。他的意思是，我没空应付这一切。德·诺瓦斯并没有被无罪释放，但他能够重获自由，并且他因谋杀埃利泽而从未受到惩罚，而这桩谋杀无疑是他干的。我的意思是，斯蒂芬给出的裁决多少有点滑稽，你知道的，就是“我们时间不够了，我也懒得管了”。然而，这是一场极大的不公。我的意思是，如果你是这个叫埃利泽的受害者的家属，你对此一定会痛心疾首。这个德·诺瓦斯就这样逃脱了法律的制裁，逍遥法外。
And so why has that happened? I mean, because if De Novas, if it's an open shut case and De Novas is obviously guilty, why has he got away with it? Okay. So I think there are two reasons and both of them contribute to a hardening of the mood against the murdered Eliazze. And the first of them is brilliantly teased out by EM Rose in her book on this whole case. And she argues that De Novas had borrowed money from Eliezer and why had he done that? Rose argues that it was because he had needed to fund his participation in the great collective Christian enterprise of the age, which is the campaign to Palestine, to the Holy Land that we remember as the Second Crusade. So this had been launched in 1147,
那么，这究竟是为什么呢？我的意思是，既然德·诺瓦斯的案子铁证如山，而且他显然有罪，为什么他能逍遥法外呢？好吧。所以我认为有两个原因，这两个原因都促使人们对被害者埃利泽的敌意情绪进一步加剧。其中第一个原因被埃姆·罗斯（EM Rose）在她关于整个案件的书中进行了极其精彩的剖析。她认为，德·诺瓦斯曾向埃利泽借过钱，他为什么要这么做呢？罗斯认为，这是因为他需要资助自己参与那个时代伟大的基督徒集体事业，也就是我们所铭记的旨在前往巴勒斯坦、前往圣地的第二次十字军东征。这场东征是在1147年发起的，
so three years after the murder of William. And it had resulted in a mood of often literally murderous hostility to Jews across Latin Christendom. And one of the things that Jewish communities over the previous century and more had come to their horror to realize was that bad news from Palestine, from the Holy Land, was invariably bad news for them. And even though, obviously, Jews in England or Germany or France or whatever have nothing to do with what is going on in the Holy Land, invariably there is blowback and Jewish communities in Western Europe tend to get the blame for what is going on in Palestine. So to give you some examples, in 1009, the Fatimid Caliph al-Hakim, aka the Muslim Caligula, orders the destruction
也就是威廉被谋杀三年之后。它在整个拉丁基督教世界引发了一种对犹太人充满敌意、甚至字面意义上充满杀戮的狂热情绪。在过去一个世纪乃至更长的时间里，犹太社群惊恐地意识到的一件事是：来自巴勒斯坦、来自圣地的坏消息，对他们而言总是意味着灭顶之灾。而且，尽管显而易见的是，英国、德国或法国等地的犹太人与圣地发生的事情毫无关系，但反噬却总是不可避免地发生，西欧的犹太社群往往要为巴勒斯坦正在发生的事情背锅。举几个例子，在1009年，法蒂玛王朝哈里发哈基姆（Al-Hakim），也就是穆斯林的卡利古拉，下令摧毁
of Constantine's Great Church of the Holy Sepulcher in Jerusalem. And this has incredible blowback in Europe. Everyone's massively upset there, understandably. And lots of Christians immediately blame the Jews for it with absolutely no evidence whatsoever. And so this is the first real mass display of anti-Jewish campaigns. So there are all kinds of examples of forced conversions, expulsions of Jewish communities across Germany, across France. Then in 1096, the First Crusade is launched and as the bands of knights are starting to form and these great bands of armed pilgrims head out to the Holy Land. So it inspires pogroms along the length of the Rhineland, so particularly notorious pogrom in Mainz where over a thousand Jews are killed. And even in Speyer where
了位于耶路撒冷的君士坦丁大帝圣墓教堂。这在欧洲引起了巨大的反噬。每个人都愤怒至极，这也可以理解。许多基督徒立刻将此归咎于犹太人，而完全没有任何证据。因此，这是反犹太运动的第一次真正的集体大爆发。于是便出现了各种各样的强制改宗案例，以及横跨德国、法国的犹太社群驱逐事件。接着在1096年，第一次十字军东征发起，随着骑士团开始集结，大批武装朝圣者前往圣地。这在莱茵河沿岸激起了大屠杀，比如美因茨发生了一场臭名昭著的大屠杀，有一千多名犹太人被杀害。甚至在施派尔，
the bishop only 12 years earlier had been saying, you know, it's a privilege to have Jews here, Jews there also get attacked and killed. So now we're in the mid 12th century and a new crusade, the second crusade, and I suppose inevitably a new wave of pogroms and persecutions. Yes, some of the details of this are horrible. So there's a rabbi who's based in England who's trying to get home from Cologne where he'd been on a visit, and en route he gets seized and beheaded. There's another rabbi in France who is mutilated by a band of crusaders, and they mutilate him in a very precise way. They inflict the five wounds suffered by Christ in his passion on the rabbi, and then they dump his body. And on the river Maine, which is a tributary of the Rhine,
就在仅仅12年前，当地的主教还在说，你知道的，在这里拥有犹太人是一种特权；但那里的犹太人同样遭到袭击和杀害。现在我们来到了12世纪中期，一场新的十字军东征——第二次十字军东征开始了，我想这也是不可避免地带来了一轮新的大屠杀和迫害。是的，其中的一些细节惨绝人寰。比如有一位定居在英国的拉比，他结束了在科隆的访问后正试图回家，在途中他被强行抓走并斩首。法国还有另一位拉比被一帮十字军残忍肢解，他们以一种非常精准的方式对其实施了残害。他们在拉比身上施加了基督受难时的五处圣伤，然后抛尸荒野。在美因河畔，也就是莱茵河的一条支流上，
so again, this sense of the Rhineland as kind of center of these atrocities. A child is found in the river, he's dead, and the Crusader say it was the Jews who did this. There are lots of Christians who are appalled by these displays of violence. So chief among them is the great preacher Bernard of Clairvaux, the great Cistercian whose sermons had played a huge role in inspiring the Second Crusade. He tours the Rhineland trying to refute the allegations that the Crusaders are bringing against the Jews. In Wurzburg, the bishop, he finds the bodies of the Jews who've been slain and he washes them and he anoints them and he buries them in the grounds of his own garden. And out in the countryside, there are lots of Christian Castellans who, a bit like
同样，这种将莱茵河视为这些暴行中心的感知再次出现。人们在河里发现了一具儿童尸体，他已经死了，而十字军却声称是犹太人干的。有许多基督徒对这些暴力行径感到震惊。其中最主要的人物是伟大的传道者克莱尔沃的伯纳德（Bernard of Clairvaux），这位伟大的熙笃会修士曾通过他的布道为第二次十字军东征的激发发挥了巨大作用。他巡视莱茵河沿岸，试图驳斥十字军对犹太人的指控。在维尔茨堡，主教发现了被杀害的犹太人的尸体，他为他们清洗、涂抹圣油，并将他们安葬在自己花园的土地上。而在乡间，有许多基督教城堡领主，他们有点像
Duchess near Norwich, when the Jews there were threatened, they sheltered the Jews in their castles. So the story isn't unremittingly a dark one, but it is clearly darkening. And, you know, it's essentially Jewish communities now across Western Christendom are having to live with the knowledge that religiously motivated violence might be provoked any time there is a kind of geopolitical crisis in Palestine. Now, superficially, there's an obvious explanation for this, which is that the Crusaders are going off to do what they see as God's work, fighting the enemies of Christ in the Holy Land, i.e. fighting Muslims. And that at the same time, that is being that the sort of mirror image of that is people
诺里奇附近的杜谢尼斯（Duchesne），当那里的犹太人受到威胁时，他们将犹太人庇护在自己的城堡里。所以这个故事并非全是一片黑暗，但它显然正在变得阴暗。而且，你知道的，现在整个拉丁基督教世界的犹太社群基本上都不得不顶着这样的认知生活：每当巴勒斯坦爆发某种地缘政治危机时，出于宗教动机的暴力随时可能被挑起。表面上看，对此有一个显而易见的解释，那就是十字军出征去履行他们眼中的上帝之职，在圣地打击基督的敌人，也就是打击穆斯林。与此同时，这背后的一种镜像则是人们
fighting Christ's enemies in Christendom itself, in Europe itself. So in other words, in this case, Jews, that the violence that they are exporting to the Holy Land, they are also now replicating within their own communities against non-Christians. But you think there's something more than that, there's another dimension to it. Yeah, because the question is, why does what happens in the Holy Land, why does it reverberate back so profoundly into Latin Christendom? I mean, there are all kinds of wars and things happening across the Mediterranean and the Near East, but they don't have the impact.
在基督教世界本身、在欧洲本土打击基督的敌人。换句话说，在这种情况下指的就是犹太人；他们输出到圣地的暴力，如今也在他们自己的社群内部针对非基督徒进行复制。但你认为事情不仅于此，还有另一个维度。是的，因为问题在于，为什么发生在圣地的事情，会对拉丁基督教世界产生如此深远的回响？我的意思是，地中海和近东地区发生了各种各样的战争和事件，但它们并没有产生这样的冲击。
And the answer to that, obviously, is that this is the Holy Land. This is where Christ was born. It's where he died. It's where he rose from the dead, Christians believe. So the Holy Land is where the innocents had been massacred on the orders of Herod, King of the Jews, and it's where Christ's suffering had been cheered on by the crowd who had refused Pilate's offer to release him, who in turn are Jews. And if you look at the accusation of child slaying, you know, this child found in the river echoes there of the massacre of the innocents. Or
而这个问题的答案显然是，这里是圣地。这里是基督诞生的地方。这里是他死去的地方。基督徒相信，这里是他死而复活的地方。因此，圣地曾按照犹太人之王希律王的命令发生过屠杀无辜婴儿的惨案，这里也曾是那些拒绝了彼拉多释放基督提议的群众狂热欢呼、催促基督受难的地方，而这群人恰恰是犹太人。如果你审视杀害儿童的指控，你知道的，这个在河里发现的儿童呼应了当年对无辜婴儿的屠杀。或者
you look at the wounds of Christ inflicted on this rabbi again, it's drawing on the New Testament narratives. And so I think that these are part of the swirl of emotion and anger on the part of Christians that Stephen, when he's presiding over the trial of De Novas, has to take account of. But he also has to take account of something else. And this is the readiness of De Novas's defense team to weaponize the almost completely forgotten murder of the apprentice boy William six years before. And when I say de Nova's defense team, I mean specifically the guy who is leading the defense, who is the Bishop of Norwich himself, a man called William Turb. And the Bishop of Norwich is a very,
你看看施加在这个拉比身上的基督圣伤，这同样取材于新约叙事。所以我想，这些都是基督徒情绪和愤怒漩涡的一部分，斯蒂芬在主持德·诺瓦斯案的审判时必须考虑到这一点。但他也必须考虑到另一件事。这就是德·诺瓦斯的辩护团队随时准备将六年前那起几乎已被彻底遗忘的学徒少年威廉被谋杀案作为武器。当我提到德·诺瓦斯的辩护团队时，我特指那个领导辩护的人，他本人就是诺里奇的主教，一个名叫威廉·特伯（William Turb）的人。诺里奇的主教是一个非常、
very able man. So he's not a royal appointee as bishops tend to be in Norman England. He's a monk in Norwich who had been an oblate, so given by his parents to the monastery as a child. He's a man of Norwich through and through. He'd been elected as bishop by his fellow monks and to quote EM Rose, an experienced courtroom authority, sophisticated, well-travelled, well-read, mature and a noted orator. And for William Turb, the chance to plead before Stephen, the King himself, is a massive opportunity for him to raise his profile because as we said he's not a royal appointee. So this is a chance for him to make himself known to the king, but it's also a chance for him to raise the
非常能干的人。所以他不是诺曼英国时期那种通常由王室任命的主教。他是诺里奇的一名修士，曾是一名献身修士（oblate），也就是孩童时期由父母送入修道院的。他是彻头彻尾的诺里奇人。他是由同修们选举为主教的，用埃姆·罗斯的话说，他是一位“经验丰富的法庭权威、老练成熟、见多识广、饱读诗书，且是一位著名的演说家”。对于威廉·特伯来说，有机会在国王斯蒂芬本人面前辩护，是他提高自己知名度的绝佳机会，因为正如我们所说，他不是王室任命的。所以这对让他名扬国王是一个机会，但这同时也是一个机会来提升
profile of his cathedral. And so by emphasizing William's status as someone who's been murdered by the Jews and therefore perhaps could rank as a martyr, it gives William Turbur the chance to potentially provide Norwich Cathedral with what up to this point it has very badly been lacking, namely some really good, authentic saintly relics, because this to be a top-class cathedral is what you need. So we mentioned Durham Cathedral has the body of St Cuthbert, Westminster Abbey has the body of Edward the confessor. And I think that probably William Turb is thinking, hmm, you know, if we can promote this little boy who's been possibly murdered by the Jews as a martyr, then brilliant. You know, we fill the gap that my cathedral has.
他所在主教座堂的知名度。因此，通过强调威廉作为一名被犹太人谋杀之人的身份，并因此可能位列殉道者，这给了威廉·特伯一个潜在的机会，为诺里奇主教座堂提供一项在此之前极其匮乏的东西，也就是一些真正优秀的、货真价实的圣徒圣物，因为要成为一座顶级的 cathedral，这正是你所需要的。所以我们提到，达勒姆主教座堂拥有圣卡斯伯特的遗体，威斯敏斯特教堂拥有宣信者爱德华的遗体。我想威廉·特伯大概在想，嗯，你知道的，如果我们能把这个可能被犹太人谋杀的小男孩塑造成一个殉道者，那就太妙了。你知道的，我们正好填补了我座堂的空白。
So do you think that this guy, William Turb, the Bishop of Norwich, is so cynical that these thoughts have genuinely gone through his mind? The cogs have turned, he's thought, it's win, win, win. You know, I'll impress people with my oratory, I'll get this very presumably influential and powerful person off, but also I will really boost my cathedral, we'll get the relics, we'll get pilgrims. Do you think he's done that cold-bloodedly or do you think he has drunk his own Kool-Aid as it were and it just happens to match or you know it's one of those things that he actually genuinely believes
那你觉得这个名叫威廉·特伯的诺里奇主教，究竟有没有精明到这些想法确实已经从他脑子里闪过了？他的大脑在飞速运转，他心想，这可真是百利而无一害啊。你知道的，我将用我的雄辩折服众人，我会让这个显然很有影响力和权势的人脱罪，但同时我也将极大地提升我的座堂，我们会得到圣物，我们会迎来朝圣者。你觉得他是冷血地这么做了，还是说他其实自己也深信不疑，或者这恰好符合他的想法，又或者（你知道的）这正是那种他真的相信、
or thinks he genuinely believes it but it also you know works to his advantage? Well self-interest and the needs of God have often coincided, I mean, and often do throughout medieval history. William Turbys, he's a monk through and through, and he's a man of knowledge through and through, and he's been personally chosen by the monks of knowledge, and he must feel that this reflects the will of God, and that God would want the cathedral to be hallowed, perhaps, by the body of a martyr. And therefore, to be sure, I mean, he's trying to get de Novas off, that's his job. But if at the same time he can raise the profile of his cathedral, then that's presumably what God wants. I'm sure that would
或者认为自己真的相信、但同时又对他的利益大有裨益的事情呢？好吧，利己主义和上帝的需求往往是不谋而合的，我的意思是，在整个中世纪历史上这屡见不鲜。威廉·特伯，他彻头彻尾是个修士，彻头彻尾是个有学问的人，而且他是被诺里奇的修士们亲自选出来的，他必定觉得这反映了上帝的意旨，并且上帝会希望这座座堂因一位殉道者的遗体而变得神圣。因此，毫无疑问，我的意思是，他正试图为德·诺瓦斯脱罪，那是他的工作。但如果在提升主教座堂知名度的同时也能达成这一点，那想必也是上帝所期望的。我确信这会
be his thinking. I mean, you might describe it as cynical, but cynicism can often be given a kind of, dare I say, sacral flavoring. So, I mean, it is a really spectacular display of victim blaming because essentially what William Turb is doing is saying that Eliezer, the murdered Jew, deserved everything he got. So to quote him, and this speech of William Turbis is quoted by Thomas of Monmouth, that Jew of whose death the night, so that's de Novas, though innocent, is accused, did, in conjunction with the other Jews then in the city, in his house, as report says, miserably torment, kill and hide in a wood a Christian boy. And the key word there is report. What does he mean by report? Well, the bishop by
是他的想法。我的意思是，你可能会称之为冷血精明，但我敢说，这种精明往往会被赋予一种——恕我直言——神圣的色彩。所以，我的意思是，这是一场极其荒谬的受害者指责（victim blaming），因为威廉·特伯本质上是在说，埃利泽——那个被谋杀的犹太人——落得什么下场都是罪有应得。引述他的话说，威廉·特伯的这段演讲被蒙茅斯的托马斯（Thomas of Monmouth）所引用：“那个犹太人，也就是那位被指控谋杀骑士（即德·诺瓦斯）的死者——尽管骑士是无辜的——曾伙同当时城里其他犹太人在他的宅邸内，正如传闻所言，极其悲惨地折磨、杀害并藏匿了一名基督教男孩在一片树林里。”其中的关键词是“传闻”。他说的传闻是什么意思？好吧，主教此时
this point has sourced various witnesses, proving, as he thinks, the murder of William of Norwich by the Jews. So one of these witnesses is a Burgess of the city called Alward, who supposedly had run into Eliezer and a fellow Jew out in Thorpewood, disposing of William's body. And you may wonder, well, why hadn't Alward, who by this point very conveniently is dead, why hadn't he revealed this at the time? And supposedly Alward had sworn an oath to the Sheriff, Don Duchesne, who is also dead, never to reveal this and only on his deathbed had he confessed it. And Thomas of Monmouth, who reports this, notes with immense satisfaction that
已经找到了各种各样的目击证人，在他看来，这些证人证明了诺里奇的威廉确实是被犹太人谋杀的。其中一位证人是城里的一位名叫阿尔沃德（Alward）的市民，据说他曾在索普伍德（Thorpwood）偶遇埃利泽和另一名犹太人在那里处理威廉的尸体。你可能会纳闷，为什么阿尔沃德当时没有揭发此事——而此时他非常“巧合”地已经死了呢？据说阿尔沃德曾向当时也是死者的治安官约翰·德·谢斯内（Don Duchesne）发誓永远不透露此事，直到临终前他才坦白。而记录了这一点的蒙茅斯托马斯带着无限的满足感指出，
both Alward and John de Chesney, the sheriff, had suffered very horrible deaths, so due punishment for their lack of enthusiasm for prosecuting the Jews. So that's one piece of evidence. Then there is a monk in Norwich who is a Jewish convert to Christianity called Theobald, and Theobald, as someone who had been a Jew, is able to reveal one of the Jews darkest secrets, and this according to Theobald is their belief that without the shedding of human blood, they will never be able to return to their homeland, to what had been Judea, Israel.
阿尔沃德和治安官约翰·德·谢斯内都遭遇了极其可怕的死亡，这是对他们缺乏追捕犹太人热情的应有惩罚。这就是其中一份证据。接着，诺里奇有一位修士，是一个由犹太人改宗基督教的人，名叫西奥巴德（Theobald）。西奥巴德作为曾经的犹太人，能够揭露犹太人最黑暗的秘密之一，而据西奥巴德所说，这个秘密就是他们的信念：如果不流淌人类的鲜血，他们将永远无法重返故土，无法回到曾经的犹太地、以色列。
Has he dreamt that up, or does that draw on an older tradition? I think drawing on the notion of the Mark of Cain, the idea that Jews are sentenced to wander and therefore perhaps as Cain had killed Abel, a blood sacrifice, so a blood sacrifice must be offered to remove the Mark of Cain. I mean, it's obviously a fabrication. There is no authentic tradition about this in Jewish thought at all. But Theobald anyway, I mean, he's all over it. So to quote Thomas of Monmouth's account of what he said, hence it was laid down, this is Theobald saying, by the Jews in ancient times that every year they must sacrifice a Christian in some part of the world to the most high God in scorn
他是做梦梦到这个的，还是说这借鉴了某种更古老的传统？我认为这是借鉴了该隐的印记（Mark of Cain）的概念，这种观点认为犹太人注定要流浪，因此正如该隐杀害亚伯需要进行血祭一样，必须献上血祭来洗刷该隐的印记。我的意思是，这显然是凭空捏造的。犹太思想中根本没有关于此事的任何真实传统。但无论如何，西奥巴德对这一切可以说是了如指掌。引述蒙茅斯托马斯对西奥巴德言论的记述：“因此，古代犹太人确立了这样的规矩——西奥巴德如是说——他们每年必须在世界上的某个地方为至高上帝牺牲一名基督徒，以此来蔑视
and contempt of Christ, that so they might avenge their sufferings on him, inasmuch as it was because of Christ's death that they had been shut out from their own country and were in exile as slaves in a foreign land." So there you have the idea of a ritual killing designed to bring about the return of the Jews to the promised land. And the third witness is, and I quote, a certain poor Christian woman who had worked as a maid for Eliazza in his household. And she is the key witness because yes, if the autopsy on William's body is accurate, you know, so if he had been gagged, if he had been stabbed with thorns, then there is evidence there for kind of ritual torture. But it's the
和亵渎基督，好让他们向基督复仇，因为正是因为基督之死，他们才被逐出自己的国家，作为奴隶流落异乡。”在这里，你看到了这种仪式性杀害的想法，旨在促使犹太人重返应许之地。第三位证人是，引述原话，“某位曾作为埃利泽家中女佣的贫苦基督教妇女”。她才是关键证人，因为是的，如果对威廉尸体的尸检是准确的，你知道的，如果他曾被塞住嘴巴、如果他曾被荆棘刺伤，那么那里确实存在某种仪式性虐待的证据。但这位女佣——据说她曾透过门缝窥视——看到了那个
maid who had peeped through a chink of the door, supposedly, who had seen the literally killer site. And again, I quote Thomas of Monmouth, while these enemies of the Christian name were rioting in the spirit of malignity around the boy, some of those present had judged him to be fixed to a cross in mockery of the Lord's passion. As though they would say, even as we condemn the Christ to a shameful death, so let us condemn the Christian so that uniting the Lord and his servant in a like punishment, we may retort upon them the pain of that reproach which they impute to us." So what is being done there? William is being tortured in the way that Christ had been tortured. It's a very, very specific anti-Christian form of death. And the people responsible for it,
简直是杀戮现场的画面。再次引述蒙茅斯托马斯的话：“正当这些基督教之敌在男孩周围带着恶毒的精神狂欢时，在场的一些人判定他是被钉在十字架上，以此来嘲弄主的受难。仿佛他们在说，正如我们判处基督可耻的死刑一样，让我们也这样判处这个基督徒，从而将主和他的仆人置于同等的惩罚中，将他们加诸于我们的耻辱，用同样的痛苦回敬给他们。”在那里究竟发生了什么？威廉正以基督受难的方式遭受折磨。这是一种非常非常独特的反基督教的死法。而根据这位女佣所说，
according to this maid, and therefore by extension the Bishop of Norwich and Thomas of Monmouth, who is reporting all this, it's not just Eliezer who's the guilty party, it's all the Jews of Norwich and by extension every Jew who lives in Christendom. The implication is that they are all doing this. So now I suppose you can see why Stephen abandons the trial in such a cack-handed way because on the one hand, you know, he has decent relations with the Jews of England, right? So he doesn't want to endorse these mad conspiracy theories. And yet at the same time, he can't ignore them, I suppose, or
以及由此推及的诺里奇主教和记录这一切的蒙茅斯托马斯，负有责任的不仅是作为主犯的埃利泽，还有诺里奇所有的犹太人，进而延伸到生活在基督教世界里的每一个犹太人。其潜台词是，他们所有人都在这样做。所以现在我想你能明白为什么斯蒂芬会以如此笨拙的方式放弃这场审判了，因为一方面，你知道的，他与英国的犹太人保持着不错的关系，对吧？所以他不想背书这些疯狂的阴谋论。但与此同时，我想他无法忽视它们，
can't just dismiss them, because there's a kind of populist enthusiasm for them. Is that what he's worried about? That the people will say, oh, he's a friend of the Jews, and we've heard that they're out to kill lots of Christians and blah, blah, blah. So he just thinks, I'll shut this down. Yeah. He doesn't want to seem like he's applying two-tier justice, you might say. Yeah. Very good. And so the result of that is that this bloke, Simon De Novas, who's a murderer and has just
或者不能直接将它们束之高阁，因为民众对这些阴谋论有着某种狂热的激情。这正是他所担心的吗？担心人们会说：“哦，他是犹太人的朋友，我们听说他们正密谋杀害许许多多的基督徒，巴拉巴拉。”所以他才觉得，干脆把这事压下来得了。是的。你可能会说，他不想让自己看起来在搞双重标准。没错。很好。而其结果就是，这个名叫西蒙·德·诺瓦斯的家伙——他是个杀人犯，刚刚
killed, because he owed this bloke money, is that basically the, it's pure self-interest. He killed this bloke that he owed money to and he's got away with it. But there's another profoundly more momentous consequence of this, which is that William's status as a martyr is kind of redeemed from oblivion and very powerfully confirmed. But there are still two further steps which are needed to absolutely consolidate William of Norwich's elevation to the ranks of the saints. And both very tellingly are set in this year, 1050, that witnesses the two trials in Norwich and London. And both of them involve the same guy who is none other than Thomas of Monmouth. So that lent Thomas's resting in the monk's dormitory after matins, and he has a vision. It's a vision of the
杀了人，仅仅是因为他欠了这家伙的钱——基本上，这完全是出于纯粹的利己主义。他杀害了自己欠债的这家伙，却逍遥法外。但除此之外，还有另一个影响更为深远的后果，那就是威廉作为殉道者的地位从湮没无闻中被“救赎”了出来，并得到了强有力的确立。然而，要彻底巩固诺里奇的威廉跻身圣徒行列，仍然需要另外两个步骤。而且非常具有暗示意味的是，这两步都发生在1050年这一年——诺里奇和伦敦的两场审判正是在这一年举行的。这两件事都涉及同一个人，此人正是蒙茅斯托马斯。当时大斋期（Lent）期间，托马斯正在修士宿舍里晨祷后休息，他做了一个异象。这是一个关于
founder and first bishop of Norwich Cathedral, a guy called Herbert de la Zinga, and Thomas describes him as being a man of venerable looks with grey hair, clothed in episcopal robes that glistened with an incomparable whiteness. And the bishop instructs Thomas of Monmouth to inform both the bishop and the prior, so the head of the monastery, that the body of the martyred boy, the martyred 12-year-old William, who originally had been buried in unconsecrated ground out in Thorpewood, that his relics must be translated as a matter of urgency into the cathedral itself. And Thomas goes to the bishop, he goes to the prior, he reveals this spectacular visitation, and they obediently place William of Norwich's relics
诺里奇主教座堂的奠基人兼第一任主教的异象，此人名叫赫伯特·德·拉津加（Herbert de la Zinga），托马斯形容他是一位面容慈祥的老者，留着灰白的胡须，身穿散发着无与伦比洁白光芒的主教法衣。主教指示蒙茅斯托马斯去通知主教和副主教（即修道院院长），那位殉道男孩的遗体——那位12岁的殉道者威廉，最初被埋葬在索普伍德未经祝圣的土地上——必须作为紧急事项将其圣物迁入主教座堂内。于是托马斯去找主教，去找副主教，他透露了这场奇迹般的显灵，他们便十分顺从地将诺里奇威廉的圣物
inside the cathedral. But the key step that Thomas of Monmouth then takes is to write a life of the martyr. And this is the very same life that one day will be discovered by MR James and published. And H.P. Lovecraft, the great American writer of horror stories, described the quality he found embodied in James' stories as an almost diabolic power of calling up horror. But I think that nothing that James ever wrote could begin to compare with the diabolic power of the life and miracles of St. William of Norwich, which Thomas of Monmouth wrote, nor with the horror of its enduring impact. Because although it's barely remembered today, although there was only the single copy
安置在了主教座堂内部。但蒙茅斯托马斯随之采取的关键一步是撰写了一部殉道者的生平。正是这部生平，日后将被M·R·詹姆斯（MR James）发现并出版。而伟大的美国恐怖小说家H·P·洛夫克拉夫特（H.P. Lovecraft）曾这样描述他在詹姆斯的故事中所发现的品质：那是一种近乎恶魔般的唤起恐惧的力量。但我认为，詹姆斯写过的任何东西，都无法与蒙茅斯托马斯所撰写的《圣威廉的生平与奇迹》那恶魔般的力量相提并论，也无法与它持久影响力的恐怖相提并论。因为尽管今天它几乎不为人知，尽管M·R·詹姆斯只找到了唯一的一份手稿，
that M.R. James found, you could argue that this is one of the most influential texts ever written in England. Now, interestingly, its influence on Norwich itself doesn't seem to have been that profound. So essentially people in the city don't take this boy martyr to their heart. So to quote EM Rose, the hard-headed Norwich merchants, artisans and aristocracy were not persuaded
你仍然可以说，这是英国历史上影响最深远的文本之一。现在，有趣的是，它对诺里奇本身的影响似乎并没有那么深远。因此，基本上城里的人并没有把这个小男孩殉道者放在心上。引述埃姆·罗斯的话：“精明强干的诺里奇商人、工匠和贵族并没有被威廉的神圣性所说服。”
of William's sanctity. And Thomas of Monmouth, who's very much the guy in charge of the branding, is absolutely irate by this. He records all kinds of details about how people just laughed at him. And I guess that they're laughing at him because you would imagine that people with local knowledge are much better qualified than outsiders to evaluate the degree of fabrication that has gone on. And I guess that most people in Norwich would probably have thought that there's nothing really that can be said with any certainty about the fate of the poor boy who died beyond that he had died too young and that his body had been found in thought wood and everything else. So the issue of how exactly he was wounded, where he was found,
而非常负责品牌运营的蒙茅斯托马斯对此怒不可遏。他记录了各种各样的细节，讲述人们是如何嘲笑他的。我猜他们嘲笑他是因为，你会觉得拥有当地情报的人比外地人更有资格去评估其中编造的成分究竟有多大。我猜诺里奇的大多数人大概都会认为，除了那个死得太年轻、尸体在索普伍德被发现之外，对于这个可怜男孩的命运，实在没有什么可以说是确凿无疑的，除此之外的一切。所以，关于他究竟是如何受伤的、他是在哪里被发现的，
everything else is essentially kind of supposition. And so I think that that's why people are skeptical and a bit embarrassed about it, I think, in Norwich. But the problem is, is that further afield, where people don't have that local context, the influence of Thomas's story very rapidly proves to be devastating. And what he has done is to provide essentially the building blocks for a story that can just be kind of endlessly recycled. So over the decades and the centuries that follow, the elements that feature in Thomas of Monmouth's account of William's murder are kind of recycled and recycled over and over again. So you get the innocent child who is brutally, ritualistically put to death. You
以及其他所有事情，本质上都不过是猜测而已。所以我想这就是为什么在诺里奇，人们对此持怀疑态度并且觉得有点尴尬的原因。但问题在于，在更远的外地，由于人们没有这种地方背景，托马斯故事的影响力很快就被证明是毁灭性的。他所做的事情，基本上是为一个可以被无休止复制的故事提供了构建模块。所以在随后的几十甚至几百家里，蒙茅斯托马斯关于威廉谋杀案叙事中的那些元素被一次又一次地反复循环。于是你看到了那个被残酷、仪式性处死的无辜儿童；
have the presentation of Jews not as individuals, but as kind of malevolent archetypes. And these archetypes are reaching back to Herod, to Cain, to Judas, to the crowds who were called on pilot to execute Christ. And just as these are in the Bible are sinister archetypes, so you have the sense that these archetypes are enduring into the present day. And you have the figure of the distraught mother looking for her child, the inquisitive maidservant who is always looking through the keyhole at these terrible murders, the perfume quality of the martyr's corpse, the miracles performed by his relics, although actually in Thomas of Monmouth's account, the miracles are brilliant. I mean, they're nothing incredible. And also interestingly,
你看到了将犹太人不再描绘为个体，而是描绘为某种充满恶意的原型。而这些原型可以追溯到希律王、该隐、犹大，以及那些在彼拉多面前叫嚣处死基督的民众。正如圣经中的这些人物是阴险的原型一样，你也会产生一种感觉，即这些原型一直延续到了当今时代。你看到了那位寻找孩子的悲痛母亲，那位总是透过钥匙孔窥视这些可怕谋杀的好奇女佣，殉道者尸体散发出的芬芳品质，以及他的圣物所显现的神迹——尽管实际上在蒙茅斯托马斯的记述中，这些神迹非常精彩。我的意思是，它们没什么大不了的。而且有趣的是，
they don't relate to the Jews. So they are, you know, you've got an ingrown toenail, you go, it's cured. It's that kind of level. They're not miracles that continue to harp on the theme of kind of Jewish iniquity. But then you get refinements, don't you, as the story spreads. So even though this is an age before print, stories can spread very quickly. I suppose you might say it's like a meme. It's like a meme that spreads, wouldn't you? So only a few years after Thomas of Monmouth's story has appeared, something similar is being told about in Blois, where Jews end up being burnt
它们与犹太人无关。所以它们是，你知道的，你长了嵌甲，你去求医，然后治好了。就是那种水平的。它们并不是那些老是纠缠于犹太人罪孽主题的神迹。但随后随着故事的传播，它变得越来越精致了，不是吗？所以，尽管这是一个印刷术发明之前的时代，故事却能传播得非常快。我想你可能会说这就像一个模因（meme）。它就像一个传播开来的模因，不是吗？因此，就在蒙茅斯托马斯的故事出现几年后，布卢瓦（Blois）也流传着类似的故事，那里的犹太人最终被布卢瓦伯爵
by the Count of Blois. And of course, the links between Stephen's England and Blois are very obvious because Stephen is the Count of Blois. So you can see it how it's kind of spreading. But it's in Germany that there's a terrible new refinement in Fulda in 1235, right? Yes, because in Fulda, the bodies of five boys are found on Christmas Day. And they say that the Jews had murdered these boys not because they were kind of reproducing the horrors of the crucifixion, but for a different reason, namely to mix the blood of the children with the Passover unleavened bread.
烧死。当然，斯蒂芬的英格兰与布卢瓦之间的联系是非常明显的，因为斯蒂芬本人就是布卢瓦伯爵。所以你可以看到它是如何传播开来的。但正是在德国，出现了一种可怕的新精致说法，那是1235年在富尔达（Fulda），对吧？是的，因为在富尔达，人们在圣诞节那天发现了五个男孩的尸体。传言称，犹太人谋杀这些男孩不是因为他们要重现十字军受难的恐怖，而是出于另一个原因，即把这些儿童的血掺入逾越节的无酵饼中。
And obviously, I mean, this is mad. The whole point is that Jews don't drink blood. And it's hard to know how and why this particular refinement comes about. Maybe it's to do with anxieties on the part of Christians themselves around the idea that they drink Christ's blood. Yeah, that seems obvious. I mean, that seems, I think is generally the kind of probably the most popular scholarly explanation for it. But the consequences are terrible. So in Fulda, 34 Jews again are burned to death. And these stories just keep on happening and
显而易见，这太荒谬了。关键就在于犹太人根本不喝血。而且很难弄清楚这种特定的精细化谣言是如何以及为什么产生的。也许这与基督徒自身对于他们饮用基督之血这一概念的焦虑有关。是的，这似乎显而易见。我的意思是，这似乎普遍被认为是学者们对此最主流的解释。但其后果是可怕的。因此在富尔达，又有34名犹太人被活活烧死。而且这些故事不断地发生、
happening and happening. Even though the notion of Jews torturing children to death, whether to replicate the crucifixion or to mix their blood with unleavened bread, is condemned very explicitly as a libel, first by an imperial commission in Germany, and then in 1253 by the papacy itself. But that begins to change, doesn't it? Because soon even the authorities, the secular authorities who previously have by and large tried to protect their Jewish populations, they give in to the kind of conspiracy theory, into the sort of populist outrage, and they start to join in the persecutions.
发生、再发生。尽管犹太人虐杀儿童以重现受难或将血掺入无酵饼的观念，先是被德国的一个帝国委员会明确谴责为诽谤，接着又在1253年遭到教宗本身的谴责。但这开始发生变化了，不是吗？因为很快，连那些以前大体上试图保护其犹太人口的世俗当局也屈服于这种阴谋论、屈服于民粹主义的愤怒，并开始加入迫害的行列。
They do. So in 1255, which is only two years after the papacy has officially condemned the blood libel, a terrible discovery is made in Lincoln and again it features a murdered child, so a small boy named Hugh is found at the bottom of a well and 90 Jews are arrested for the boy's murder and this time it's done on the orders of the King himself, Henry III, who takes them to the Tower of London. 18 are hanged, the murdered boy is entombed in Lincoln Cathedral and hailed by locals as a martyr and he is kept there as a kind of you know one of the great saints of Lincoln Cathedral right the way up to the Reformation. Even though the papacy itself very pointedly refuses to confirm the canonization,
确实如此。因此在1255年——就在教宗正式谴责血祭诽谤仅仅两年后——林肯发生了一起可怕的发现，其中同样涉及一个被谋杀的儿童：一个名叫休（Hugh）的小男孩被发现在一口井的底部，90名犹太人因谋杀该男孩而被捕，这一次是奉国王亨利三世（Henry III）本人的命令进行的，他将这些人押送到了伦敦塔。18人被绞死，被谋杀的男孩被安葬在林肯主教座堂，并被当地人尊为殉道者，他一直被供奉在那里，你知道的，作为林肯主教座堂最伟大的圣徒之一，一直持续到宗教改革时期。尽管教宗本人非常刻意地拒绝批准对他的册封，
this does not inhibit the growth of the cult of little Saint Hugh as he comes to be called. You can see the stone base of his shrine in Lincoln Cathedral to this day and there's now a sort of a statement drafted by kind of the church and local Jewish groups about you know bigotry and persecution and stuff but it's a reminder of how widespread and how popular actually this kind of stuff was. Yeah and by this point even the church itself itself, which in its higher echelons had tried to stand against this blood libel. By now, church councils, church scholars, even they are starting to repudiate the notion that Jews and Christians might share a common humanity. So already
但这并没有阻碍“小圣休”（正如人们开始称呼他的那样）崇拜的增长。直到今天，你仍然可以在林肯主教座堂看到他神龛的石质底座，如今那里还有一份由教会和当地犹太人团体起草的关于狂热和迫害的声明，但这仍然是一个提醒，提醒人们这种东西曾经是多么广泛和受欢迎。是的，而到了这个时候，连教会本身——其高层原本曾试图抵制这种血祭诽谤——也沦陷了。到了现在，教会会议、教会学者，甚至连他们也开始否认犹太人与基督徒可能共享共同人性的观念。早在
in 1215, a Lateran council held by Innocent III, the most powerful of all the great medieval popes, the guy who had launched the Alpergenzian Crusade, had ordered Jews at all times to be marked off in the eyes of the public from other peoples through the character of their clothing. In 1267, sexual relations between Jews and Christians are banned by the formal decree of another Church Council, and in 1275 a Franciscan in Germany draws up a law code which makes it a capital offence for Jews and Christians to have sexual relations. And in 1290, Edward I, so he's the son of Henry III, the King of England, he pushes the logic of this, you know, this baneful trend, I guess, to its kind of ultimate conclusion, when he orders all the Jews in England to leave for good, and they will not return until
1215年，由英诺森三世（Innocent III）主持的拉特兰公会议（Lateran council）——他是所有中世纪伟大教宗中最权势滔天的一位，也就是发起阿尔比十字军东征的那位——就曾下令犹太人在任何时候都必须在公众眼中通过其服饰的特征与其他人区分开来。1267年，另一场教会会议通过正式法令禁止犹太人与基督徒发生性关系；而在1275年，德国的一位方济各会修士起草了一部法律，将犹太人与基督徒发生性关系定为死罪。到了1290年，英格兰国王爱德华一世（Edward I，即亨利三世之子）将这种恶劣趋势的逻辑推向了它的终极结论，
the time of Oliver Cromwell. So I guess you could say that in that sense, even though the people of Norwich laughed at Thomas of Monmouth for promoting William as a saint, it's Thomas of Monmouth who has the last kind of sinister laugh. Yeah, the last baneful laugh. And so his book, That Life of William of Norwich, that's what we began with. You know, the title sounds very boring, but actually you could argue it is one of the most sinister, poisonous and influential texts ever published in England. Yeah, because the blood libel continues to be repeated even to this day.
他下令英格兰所有的犹太人永远离开，直到奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）时代他们才得以重返。所以你可以说，从某种意义上说，尽管诺里奇的人民曾因托马斯·莫玛斯将威廉宣传为圣徒而嘲笑他，但最终带着阴险笑容的却是蒙茅斯托马斯。是的，带着那种有害的阴险笑容。所以他的那本书——《诺里奇的威廉生平》，正是我们开篇所谈到的。你知道的，书名听起来非常枯燥，但实际上你可以认为它是英国出版过的最阴险、最恶毒、影响最深远的文本之一。是的，因为血祭诽谤至今仍在被不断重复。
All right. Well, what a chilling and instructive story, Tom. Thank you very much. We will see you next time for something hopefully a little bit more cheerful. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了。汤姆，这真是一个令人不寒而栗且充满教益的故事，非常感谢你。我们下期节目再见，希望下次能聊点稍微轻松愉快的话题。再见。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。